ah also okay five nights a complete win  because we won ten tempest compared to  the other one  oh that's actually very simple and very  well timed and let's do the arrow game  again peter rookies tonight tonight's a  very easy edo game yeah exactly yeah and  you have to go kings you have to you  know takes on after you go a7  ah okay yeah basically i i just wanted  to highlight that yeah it's uh okay so  takes takes king c7 we now immediately  take take we take already and after king  b8 we already come king for hindi fight  just okay we're gonna see this we're  going to see this and actually as you  pointed out it's about a million moves  more for white than the line that we  previously compared it to  yeah  and that's it  that is it ali reza takes the lead in  his match against of duda it looks like  alireza is back  yeah ali is back actually i was  mentioning million it's just one tempo